hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast implement high-throughput
3d image analysis for samples from
subcellular structures to steroid
presented by oxana Steranko PhD and
Stephen Luke we're excited to bring you
this educational web seminar presented
my lab roots and sponsored by molecular
devices molecular devices is one of the
world's leading providers of
high-performance bioanalytical
measurement systems software and
consumables and is dedicated to helping
customers unravel the complexity of
biological systems included within a
broad product portfolio our platforms
for high-throughput screening genomic
and cellular analysis colony selection
and microplate detection these
innovative instruments combined with
scientific expertise essays and
analytics tools for protein and cell
biology enable scientists to explore
life's most important questions to learn
more about molecular devices please
visit www cooler devices calm i'm judy
oracle efforts and i'll be your
moderator for today's event before we
begin I would like to remind everyone
that this event is interactive we
encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
and anytime you want during the
presentation just click on the green Q&A
button located in the lower left of the
presentation window and type your
question into the box that appears on
the screen or answer as many questions
that we have time for at the end of the
presentation also please notice that
you'll be viewing the presentation in
the slide window to enlarge the window
just click on the screen icon located on
the lower right and finally if you have
any trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation please click on the support
button at the top right of the
presentation window or use the Q&A
button to let us know that you're having
a problem thank you before we hear from
the presenters I would like to introduce
British Andy PhD senior product manager
at molecular devices
hi everybody I'm Gretchen d product
manager of cellular imaging here at
medical devices I'm extremely excited to
have you join our webinar discussing the
implementation of high-throughput 3d
image analysis for spheroids as well as
sub salil structures I'm going to go
over an overview of how you do high
content screening what that means and
how the image Express micro and
medexpress software packages fit into
that workflow and then we'll turn it
over to Oksana will be reviewing a
couple of very exciting screens of
steroids done in 3d so 3d data out of
those screens and then Steve will be
discussing how you set up 3d assay for
subsidence structures and then we should
have some time for a Q&A icon and
screening or hike on and imaging is is
an aspect of automated imaging the
process where the conventional
microscope might be to put your slides
on a on a manual microscope or a semi
semi auto be microscope with the
automated stage or maybe some automated
focusing you acquire some images and
then what how do you make sense of that
those those images that you collected
you need to piece together some software
and analysis routines maybe write some
scripts and that can all of this
workflow can typically take hours
now with high content screening you can
acquire the wide variety of assets as
you saw build with that stack you can
acquire that those different
applications from slides from six world
dishes from 3d for from 1536 well plates
you're quite fast at very high
throughput you have image analysis that
can happen at this in parallel on the
same time as acquisition and you can
turn those numeric data into meaningful
results a complete solution for image
imaging starts with acquiring your
images and for 3d data you will be
acquiring z stacks of data the data will
be quite and z you want to identify
objects you undo that image analysis
which steve look will be showing you
some examples of and you want to do that
in 3d space not just 2d you want to turn
those images whether they're 2d or 3d
into multiple parameters and data output
you want to get a number of measurements
out of out of your images and we'll be
talking about how you do 3d counting 3d
segmentation 3d volume and distance
measurements and then you want to make
sense of all those numbers in this
automate in this overall high content
workflow make sense of the data either
hit finding or ec 50s as examples
molecular visor prides a complete
solution for that imaging workflow
starting at the top of your screen with
the image Express systems which I'll
talk to you a little bit in the next
slide it's you have a data management
solution that's automatically part of
that workflow that that the images go
into medexpress automatically talks to
that that that data management solution
MDC store puts the measurements that are
made on those images into that same same
location and then you have a way to date
in mind that with a cutie express
molecular basis products enable hundreds
of automated imaging applications all of
these things these acids are being done
by some of our customers we'd like to
say we enable apoptosis to zebrafish
you've got a biological problem we can
solve that in an automated workflow for
for you angiogenesis as an example
coculture assays me to jail cell culture
assays very complicated 3d assays to be
able to quantify that mitochondrial
localization will see little bit of a
medic on a sale in Steve stock stem
cells stem cell assays and zebrafish
assays so from apoptosis to zebrafish
are things that people do with our
products and we try to enable those and
make them easier and faster we enable
these hundreds of applications with a
portfolio of intelligent imaging
solutions that allows you to do
breakthrough research the image Express
micro xls is a proven product recognized
in the high content imaging space I
noosed offerings the image press micro
for which we've just released which
takes the best features and benefits of
the image of stress micro and brings
that to market along with the ability to
be filled upgradable confocal so you
allows you to grow with your needs and
the image assess microcon focal product
which we launched at the end of last
year is a product that's ideal for these
some of the 3d asses will be speaking
about
the other enabling tool is men express
which is not only runs the image Express
systems but is also the image analysis
tool box you can do turnkey applications
with application modules things like new
readout growth and cell cycle and all
the way on the continuum of increasing
flex being complex it e to the running
journals which are our macros which will
enable powerful hardware software
decision making as part of the automated
workflow this webinar is going to focus
on custom modules which is something
that bridges the gap between application
modules and macros that once you've
written in a custom module it can be
rerun as an application module talking
to you about how you do 3d application
modules but in the past with these these
custom modules have enabled things like
mitotic spindle and centrosome detection
label-free proliferation assays not just
nur it out code but identifying puncta
on your new rights and and even in
migration assays so on that note i will
turn it over to Oksana who will be
talking to you about some of the 3d
asset she's done on steroids thank you
doctor chanting now I'd like to
introduce dr. Ochs honest orenco
research scientists consider Luke
applications scientists both from
molecular devices work Rana is working
on development of new technologies for
imaging and high content analysis she
has prior experience working on drug
discovery and drug development and
several biotech companies in the San
Francisco Bay Area the focus of her
current scientific research is on
development methods for high-throughput
in vitro toxicity screening including 3d
models Oksana has a PhD in biochemistry
and bachelor's degree in biology Stephen
is working as a customer representative
for the high content screening software
he has a bachelor's degree in biology
from niagara university and more than 10
years of experience in high content
analysis and cellular imaging Sgt field
is a core imaging facility manager at
Thomas Jefferson University in
Philadelphia please join me in welcoming
pathana sorento I will now turn the
presentation over to her hello thank you
everyone for joining our webinar I will
be able to present our studies about
phenotypic characterization of compound
effects on liver spheroids using
confocal imaging and 3d image analysis
this fork was done in collaboration with
cellular dynamics international
cell models becoming more complex in
order to better mimic in vitro
environment and provide more
biologically relevant systems for drug
discovery and toxicity testing there is
increasing interest in exploring
three-dimensional spheroids for modeling
development and keisha biology
accordingly development of higher
throughput sa using 3d cultures is
active area of investigation
the goal of this study was to develop
and evaluate high content imaging
methods to investigate toxicity effects
on the morphology of Louisville roads
using techniques for confocal imaging
and 3d image analysis induced
pluripotent stem cells derived
hepatocytes present available models
that can closely resemble the phenotypes
and functionality of primary hepatocytes
and also minimize variability and other
limitations we've used IPSC derived the
butter sites from cellular dynamics
international for this study scientists
from cellular dynamics michael hancock
and colby carlson developed a protocol
for cell culture information spheroids I
sill hepatocyte swept replated first
into 6-well format then after seven days
played it into the low attachment in
Cyril or corny inflates formation of
steroids was observed in 48 hours thence
parents were three deities compounds
going to have liver toxicity for 72
hours after that life thyroids were
stained with calcium first a TD on
homodimer or other dyes spirits were
imaged using molecular devices image
Express micron confocal instrument
images were analyzed using 2d or 3d
image analysis to define finna typically
doubts which include morphological
changes of spheroids as well as
intensities and also count of different
cell types we use princely develop stain
in protocol and concentration and one
step die edition that eliminates the
need for fixing cells or repeated worst
steps you can see here images of
representatives fearo's stained with a
mixture of three dice contain am was
used to measure cell metabolic activity
viability
variety of morphological parameters
first was used to measure total cell
count and nuclear shape and I tedium
homodimer was used to mark dead or
necrotic cells
here presented composite images of
spheroids treated with compounds known
to have liver toxicity you can see
phenotypic changes as a result of
compound treatment
common issues facility imaging described
by others include efficiency of light
penetration into the dense object like
sphaeroides also light scattering by
cells and hyper ground from out of plane
fluorescence this issues tend to be less
important for smaller sphere oils like
used in prison study confocal microscopy
provides efficient background rejection
and sharper images in this study images
were taken using automated confocal
microscope with a large field of view
camera the system effectively captures
steroid in a single image using 10x
objective at this magnification may
typically took from 11 to 17 images 5
micron or more in distance images
acquired this 20x objective provided
even better visualization of details in
the present study 3d analysis of images
was accomplished using recently added
features of matter expressed software
this software converts a stack of 2d
images obtained by confocal acquisition
in facility space is appropriate
detection and segmentation of objects
spheroids can be characterized by their
size and also intensities on the graph
you can see measurements characterizing
spheroid as a single object you can see
through it three date with material male
Kareem is different in size because of
toxicity induced loss of spheroid
integrity and also you can see decreased
viability staining like intensity for
Fitzie channel
individual cells and subcellular objects
can be analyzed and characterized with
in spirits custom model editor are
typically used for the analysis the
analysis included cell scoring for
defining sales nucleocytoplasmic on- for
selective markers
on this slide you can see segmentation
of cytoplasm
and here you can see analysis masks
cells cordon analysis allow to define
spheroid objects in light blue also live
cells shown in yellow dead cells shown
in blue and cytoplasm positive for
calcium am in pink here we present an
individual seaplanes individuals a plane
surface segmented and analyzed as 2d
images for example for nuclear cloud or
cells calling features then the objects
were connected by best match function if
his user-defined maximums it allowed for
displacement of each object relative to
another object for example about 5
microns for the maximum displacement for
the nuclear and 20 microns for cytoplasm
nuclei or individual cells were
segmented and scored in a contents of
layered 3d volume ideally without
missing objects or count in the same
object files these steps allow defining
and counting the number of total sales
number of concealing and positive or
negative cells number of a tedium
homodimer positive and negative cells in
addition the intensities of individual
cells can be defined in different colors
as well as the volumes diameters
distances between the objects the larger
spheroid mask can be used to define
number of smaller object within spheroid
or externally significant changes in
spheroid phenotypes and cell content
well seen after treatment with
hepatotoxic compounds many spirits lose
this physical shape if you disintegrated
loose or flattened or irregular help
cells detached from the main body or
show condensed new play use of cell
death
quantitative analysis of images include
finding parameters that allow assess
morphological features of steroids and
also the content and complexity the
volume diameter and intensities were
measured and also the number of calcium
positive cells as life the number of
each idiom homodimer cells as dead and
also averaged volumes and intensities of
cells positive for these markers
concentration-dependent decrease in a
number of viable cells was observed as a
result of compound treatment and also
increase in a number of dead cells
enrich fluorescent intensity for
continuum was dramatically reduced for
entire spheroid and also for individual
cells the average volume of cytoplasm
stained miss calcium was also decreased
the number of metabolically active
calcium positive cells the volume of
positive cells over the fluorescent
intensity provided the greatest
sensitivity slowly diameter volume or
count of dead cells changed
significantly did not follow for
parametric concentration-dependent
responses in contrast is a number of
life cells as well as calcium intensity
of volume of calcium positon cells
resulted in significant as a windows and
successful feed into for parametric
dose-response curves for the study of
cytotoxicity mechanism we also evaluated
apoptosis and mitochondria integrity
activation of apoptosis using caspase-3
seven died was measured 24 hours after
compound treatment you can see typical
activated gas phase staining pattern for
cells treated with material mercury
mitochondria potential was evaluated
with my toe tracker orange time you can
see decrease in stain for sphaeroides
three degrees and demise in a
spirit sa was characterized using the
representative set of about 50 compounds
that included known cytotoxic and
hepatotoxic agents plus six chemicals
considered say or non-toxic table here
present selected set of abeta toxic
compounds known liver toxins like
aflatoxins and rotten all wittle mercury
and dickinson drugs like mitomycin the
doxorubicin antidepressants like
haloperidol and other types of drugs we
also compared effects for selected
compounds on steroids made from
transformed liver cells hep g2 spheroids
very larger in size / st. cell number
plated since hep g2 spheroids appear to
continuously grow in a culture during
compound treatment also there was marked
decrease in a size of hep g2 spheroid as
well as decrease in a total cell number
which was in contrast to the not
dividing isself hepatocyte steroids a
comparison of IC 50 values for compounds
between two cell types is given in a
table there are significant differences
between the two cell models with respect
to antiproliferative compounds the IC 50
s for hep g2 were in the normal range
well IC 50 is for hepatocyte steroids
were significant shift 'add in contrast
for maturity of hepatotoxic compounds
they don't inhibit replication for
example ketoconazole showed similar
effects in both cell models
in a summary 3d spheroid cell model
combined with high content 3d is a short
promise is a sensitive and reproducible
screening tool for assessing sabado
toxicity and while in vivo of toxicity
assessment reminds the gold standard 3d
models can accelerate the process by
allowing rapid compound prioritization
for in vivo testing and establishing
mechanism of action in addition I would
like to briefly describe another model
similar approach was taken for imaging
and analysis of steroids in semi solid
media images were acquired using
confocal option these slices were
captured 5 to 10 micron apart several
seaplanes presented here show how the
focus changes for different objects when
moving in 3d dimension analysis allow
defining cells in different images and
then connecting those in 3d space custom
model allowed count and characterization
of individual sphaeroides and also count
numbers of life and dead cells missing
spheroids compound treatment resulted in
decreased numbers and size of colonies
and also decrease of the number of live
cells and total cells 3d analysis links
a fob jecht in different zip lanes and
also enables characterization and
morphometric analysis of spheroids in 3d
you can see concentration-dependent
effects and four parameter curve feeds
for selected compounds the number of
spheroids number of live cells total
number of cells number of live cells per
spheroids all those three downs have a
good fit into four parameter curve
I would like to acknowledge scientists
from cellular dynamics international
Michael Hancock Kobe Carlton and David
Mann for their contribution for this
project and also scientists from
molecular devices especially three shame
it long for technical help and others
for development of instrumentation and
software
if you have additional questions about
cell culture protocols or staining
imaging or analysis please contact
myself or David Mann and molecular
devices or cellular dynamics thank you
so much for your attention
Thank You Oaks Thank You oak sauna three
poll questions will appear on your
screen please select your answers then
close the poll questions by clicking on
the X in the right corner thank you I
will now turn the presentation over to
Steven Luke 3d analysis can be added to
different scales of samples Oksana is
talking to say about relatively large
samples multi cellular analysis and
spheroids her presentation will also be
a scientific discussion on the benefits
of 3d analysis I will cover a different
set of material concentrating on
subcellular analysis and rather than a
scientific presentation I will discuss
how you might approach building a volume
module this is the set of wells I think
as a backdrop for making the module it
is a simple toxicity essay with Retta
known and one to ten solutions and the
control well these are some of the
sample images control treatment is on
the bottom left so in healthy stream
mitochondria and the 5 micro molar
concentration of retinal images are on
the top right showing clumpy
mitochondria it is important to note
that for some essays you can create
pretty simple modules to get a
measurement to classify cells one way or
another for example if all we needed to
do was have a module which detects
toxicity of a treatment based on
mitochondria sin rather than create a
set of masks segmenting mitochondria the
module could just create a mask that
covers all the mitochondria and measures
the intensity variation under that mask
intensity variation is a texture
measurement where clumping mitochondria
have fewer smaller brighter spots and so
have a higher variation than those that
have long stringy relatively dim might
occur
J for this presentation and in the
spirit of high content we will use a
more in-depth module that can give us
more values like volume of mitochondria
or the ratio is stringy to Columbia
mitochondria
CD data can mean different things
depending on what is acquired and there
are different ways you can segment data
based on what you want to get out of it
the first and most obvious approach is
to work with objects as volumes you can
take advantage of the three dimensional
nature of the data the better filter
process and classify the objects in this
pattern you take source images which are
just two dimensional planes acquired at
various focal planes and you analyze
them together as a unit and you use
dedicated 3d processing steps to do so
the next approach is to process each
plane individually as two dimensional
data then when done processing in 2d you
combine the results in two volumes using
various connection rules this allows you
to use any of the wide variety of 2d
processing steps that are available
while still resulting in volume objects
as the results I'd finally you're as 3d
data may just be a combination of 2d
planes without any real connection
between them so you can analyze them
plane by plane without introducing any
3d requirements for example if your
sample as a tissue with Z steps much
larger than the size of the objects
being analyzed or for 3d based migration
assays where you just need to track
cells moving from the top to the PI a
bottom of your membrane this is the
custom module editor as a quick
introduction to the user interface on
the left side of the window you'll see a
series of step cards each of which is a
processing step which which are strung
together and sequences to form the
module at the top of the window is the
ribbon was buttons to add step cards to
the module the arrow points to a group
of step cards that are dedicated for 3d
analysis on the right side of it is a
slider that you can use to choose a Z
plane
view in the image grid at the bottom is
a film strip which shows a thumbnail for
the results of each step and on the last
slide I talked about a third approach to
3d images where you can basically treat
the data as just went of 2d images to do
that you can turn this option off
processing images in 3d can take time
based on the number of images you have
this section allows you to crop the
images in XY and Z which makes creating
the module faster but still allows you
to run the module on the complete image
when it's time to do so so let's look at
the first part of our module finding
nuclei to do this we will segment
entirely in three dimensions to begin
let's look at the data source image that
be can be quite textured especially with
confocal source images so to ensure that
we segment the image well we will first
use a 3d average filter to smooth out
the sample with the nuclei smooth it is
time to segment again we will use a 3d
tool this one is designed to find
spherical objects it is capable of
finding things a little more complex and
spheroids but generally is good for
things where the centroid remains
roughly the same from plane to plane
this is one of two step cards designed
for 3d segmentation the other find fast
3d objects allow some rougher shapes but
finds vehicle objects does a better job
of finding bunch together things sitting
on top of each other the result of the
segmentation is a cell map a cell map is
a colorful mask where each individual
nuclei is we represented by a color as
you navigate through Z the objects
remain the same color now we process the
source image then segments and processed
image this is a good point to review our
source and our segmentation to make sure
the segmentation looks correct to do
that use the compare images step card
and choose the original source image and
the result of the segmentation you can
also open the images up in this 3d
viewer to make sure the shapes look
correct as wine
you
the next thing we need to do is segment
out the mitochondria and if possible
differentiate between healthy and
unhealthy mitochondria the unhealthy the
healthy mitochondria are long tubes and
neither of the 3d segmentation steps
work well with tubes so there's a good
time to switch to the second approach to
finding 3d volumes segment the images in
2d then connect the 2d segments into 3d
volumes this gives us access to a lot
more segmentation options for this
module we will use angiogenesis objects
angiogenesis is a good tool for finding
tubes which is great for the healthy
mitochondria but it also tracks nodes
which makes for a great mask detecting
unhealthy clumpy mitochondria
before we run and Joe Genesis though we
will add a pre-processing step we want
to separate and highlight relatively
small structures from blur or smear the
LOD filter or lap lacing on a Gaussian
filter is a great tool for this
with LG used to highlight the
mitochondria it is time to run
angiogenesis angiogenesis produces for
masks the first is a mask of the tubes
we will be using for the healthy
mitochondria the second is called nodes
which is what we're going to use for
clumpy mitochondria the other two are
aligned along the center of the tubes
they dot at the center of each node and
we won't be using them for these for
this module angiogenesis produces two
dimensional masks our module requires
volumes so we need to connect the 2d
masks into 3d volume maps there are
three connection rules to help with this
do not connect objects generates a 3d
body map without actually connecting
objects good for the win when the
objects are smaller than the sea step
but you still want to accumulate results
in 3d connect by best match connects
objects on neighboring planes in a
one-to-one basis it is best to use this
when you know your objects have no
branching or tree-like structures for
our module we will use connect by
touching which connects objects one and
many too many basis allowing for complex
structures and branching
we have the mess that we really need to
make measurements we want from the
module now but we need one more masks as
the apparent to include all the
mitochondria and the nuclei for the cell
there are different strategies to do
this kind of fun what you need to get
out of the module we have a good nuclei
mask so we could define a cell as those
pixels in and around the nuclei which
would look like this or we could create
a more complete mask that segments all
of the important pixels post nuclei and
mitochondria together to generate a cell
mask which would look like this for our
module since we are using numbers
generated by specific masks for the
nuclei and the mitochondria we could use
the first approach without most much of
an issue and we could and we would
prefer doing it this way since it is
much quicker and this module is long
enough as it is but in the beginning of
this talk we mentioned about a we
mentioned a single mask that we could
generate and measure intensity variants
as a stand-in texture measurement that
we could use if we didn't need volumes
or other high content numbers to get
that measurement we would need the
second more accurate cell mask and so
for this presentation I will quickly
walk you through the generation of this
more complete mask
to start generating the cell map we will
first combine the nuclei the
mitochondria into a single image to make
it easier to find all the pixels we care
about well then blur the image was a
dilate to smudge out the details so we
can connect masks and then we will
segment the smudged cell pixels into a
binary mask how you do this is dependent
on a lot of the dependent a lot on the
quality of your images for this set we
can use a simple threshold but there are
other options to get the complex shape
that you may need what is important here
is to get all the pixels that you care
about not necessarily to split the
individual cells yet after we have our
masks will add a filter to get rid of
the little things that come from noise
or debris in this example we'll remove
any objects which don't at some point
touch the nucleus result will be our
cell pixels all the pixels that will
part of oneself or another splitting the
cells is the next big hurdle to do that
we'll use watershed lines for which we
need to gather to intermediaries a
representation of the nuclei you can use
in the marker to generate exactly one
cell / nuclei and a second to generate
intensity peaks between the larger cell
pixel objects we will start with this
second image the intensity Peaks will
come from the distance map an image
where we will take each pixel's
intensity as a measure the distance from
the edge of the object will use it in
the cell pixels mask to get the
intensity Peaks we need then to generate
the nuclear markers we will add three
steps nuclei volume mask has the objects
we need but isn't binary and the nuclei
which are next to each other don't
have an empty pixel between them so we
all trace the edges of the nuclei and
cut those edges out of the volume mask
and in the process turn the nuclei
volume into binary markers with the
nuclear markers in place we have what we
need for watershed lines watershed lines
will trace lines along peak intensities
and we'll be sure to draw a line between
every pair of neighbor and marker
objects we combine that result with cell
pixels and we have our 2 d-cell masks
since this is a firing module we will
combine this 2d masks into 3d volume
maps using connection role and this time
since we expect a one-to-one connection
from plane to plane we will use connect
by best match the final step is to
define what gets measured what numbers
to generate to do that we switch to the
measurements tab select our cell volume
map as the object mask and then proceed
to add additional feature masks for each
thing was in the cell that we want to
measure amely the nuclei stringy
mitochondria and clumpy mitochondria
assign which images to measure and which
or with which mask we can select which
measurements to make for each mask and
image for example for the cell volume
mask and the mitochondria source image
we can measure the intensity variation
to get that one single measurement I've
described a few times now then we can
add a name additional measurements for
each of the other masks until we have
the set that we want we can run the
module and look at the result mask
measurements per cell and ensure that we
have the numbers and the masks that we
need once we save the module we can say
once we have the module we can save it
and once saved we can run it from med
express or med express power core to
know the rate the numbers over
a plate I hope this helps you build your
own three dimensional analysis and thank
you for your attention thank you up
sonnet and Stephen for the informative
presentation some poll questions will
appear on your screen please select your
answers then close the poll questions
like by clicking on the X in the right
corner thank you it's time for Q&A if
you have a question you would like to
ask oksana or Steven please do so now
just click on the green to in a button
at the lower left of the presentation
window type your question into the box
that appears on your screen and click on
the send button or answer as many of
your questions as we have time for dr.
Chandra will now moderate the QA already
thanks for joining that quite a few
questions I'm going to try and group
some of the questions that are similar
together there are three questions
around for Oksana around how the assay
and cells were grown and done some are
read each of the three questions and
then I'll come on to them all together
excuse me there was one question about
how the cells are whatever plate is used
and how the cells are centered in the
plate let me just a chicken oh yeah can
you image in a 96-well plate in an
automated fashion on a low binding plate
the square it may not be at the same XY
position how can you get the you know
the spheroid centered and why'd you
answer those while I look for the other
questions that are similar so thank you
so much for your questions so I will be
happy to answer in fact indeed to Center
in steroids for imaging and automatic
imaging is kind of very important point
and actually be able to mitigate it by
two types of blades so one type of place
is infertile u-shape low attachment
place they come either in kind of 96
format or 384 format those are from
Cornyn and another type is inserted
late-stage are 96 format they shall fled
button but they have conical well so
that flat part is very narrow so in both
cases because we have like large cute of
you camera the able is no problem cover
all steroid in any location of the
wealth in 10x magnification for 20 x
magnification it's also possible in
automated fashion when we use in corn
and plate which kind of this u-shape
allow thyroid actually to be centered in
a veil so which allowed to capture
entire object without splitting yes that
answers that question there's another
question about whether you can image a
sphere is over time in the system yes
actually she sure we have done this
study actually monitor formation of
thyroid and the kind of acute effects of
some drugs so you can do it by using
time-lapse so you sit up like maybe 20
minutes lapse or to do overnight
experiment and you can monitor formation
of steroids in a real time and then
there's a question that Alice tan
searches what is you know what system
would is done in these were all done in
the Ames express microcontroller product
sheet sets up the assay and then puts
the plate in the system you can do that
with a robot or by hand and then the
system is run and you can do them either
as the endpoint assay like I presented
this presentation or as she mentioned as
a time
can you discuss a different question is
can you discuss a little bit but you're
staining procedure and how how you added
the dyes and body remove them and decide
that this is another kind of important
topic because those steroids are kind of
not attached to the button there are
some challenges for staining and version
so the protocol which we develop
actually include just single step
addition of dice so usually they add
like 3x concentrated dynamics in PBS
directly to to the wealth without
removal media or anything and c allow
like at least two hours for staining we
usually keep during this two hours late
back to incubator and with those dice
which we use its kind of sufficient to
penetrate inside the roids and we don't
wash and die out so we just image data X
place so this confer call system it has
very nice the ground rejection so it's
not a problem at all um so I remember so
the there's not a question of time lapse
I remember that one of the daily
published was on just doing cells and
fearful nation over time without a stain
have you also done it with stains we
done delightful measurement with stains
ah we have not done it but it is
possible yes so it's just kind of the
matter of to choose the right dice so it
wouldn't fade away or it wouldn't cause
toxicity I would imagine that this kind
of here how cells stained ice could be
useful for this purpose or maybe if you
use the first stain in a lower
concentration it's also kind of them
okay option question for Steve these are
two related questions are there tools
available to estimate cells verification
or distribution in 3d analysis the
switch from cell cells or other sphere
and then there's the the drag question
is can you make can perform distance
measurements in 3d so those two
questions I think are a little bit
related Steve can you take that sure yep
so add the customizable thought it does
let you measure positional information x
y&z position there is a measurement for
each object that is the distance to its
nearest neighbor so that gives you
dispersion measurements and then there's
also a measurement that you can make on
there's a 3d distance map so you can
have distance of one object from some
common source or from something in a
different channel or a different type of
object here's a question that I'll take
can the software analyze images from
other images other than the image
Express yes we have ways to import data
from third-party imagers we haven't you
know there's a limited set of instance
we've tested it on so it really depends
on the format of the data whether we can
import it or not and we've done it with
some both compared and collaborator
instruments so it really depends on what
you have so let me go back and look at
the questions again
d the question for you on how long 3d
analysis in a 384-well plate with my
tape so that depends a lot on the module
there's on simple modules like we were
talking about that single mask that you
could use to measure them variation
under that can take just a few minutes
three to five minutes per 384-well plate
and then as something that's a little
bit more robust like that to the whole
mitochondrial volume if you have lots of
Z plane that could take upwards of I'm
sorry i'm at three minutes per plate
three hours per plate that is a big one
could take a you know 30 hours you if
it's a big investment of time this also
medexpress Power Core which can then
speed up the analysis time by
distributing lee analysis around
different computers and you're looking
at maybe reducing the three hour quick
Moggle down to 45 minutes and taking
that 30 hour down to maybe five hours
yeah you can maybe get a sometimes video
10x improvement two maybe three or four
hours right and there's a question
there's a question I'm just go back to
Oksana well did use air or water or oil
objectives for your essays actually it
was all air objective yeah no oil in
this essay Steve what are the three
connection rules again this reconnection
rules there's am do not connect objects
this one creates a volume map but does
not connect objects from one plane to
another so it's very good for when you
have like with a nuclei in your spheroid
the nuclei might not actually appear on
multiple Z planes we still want to count
the number through Z and so this would
allow you to accumulate data through
three
3d without actually connecting anything
the second role is connected by touching
so if there's any overlapping pixels
from one plane to the next they're going
to be connected as a single object in
three dimensions and then the third one
is connected by best match and this is
going to be a one-to-one connection from
one plane to the next and it's going to
use size and position to determine what
object to connect if there's more than
one that might possibly connect it will
determine the best match based on size
and position um Steve does a question on
whether you need a confocal system or
actually sounds a confessional has our
existing image excess micro XL can you
do these analyses in both whitefield or
confocal mode you can do them in
whitefield mode you don't need the kind
of local the confocal will give you an
improved segmentation because it's
removing a lot of the out-of-focus light
and then the depth or the 3d size of the
object might be extended so it might be
measured as deeper and the volume
overestimated in a wide field system but
it's still possible to segment in both
wives build n 3n comfortable ok thanks
Steve there's a couple of questions
about if this webinar is going to be
available it it I think they've been
answered privately but they will it will
be available and we'll let the attendees
know when it is posted and it's usually
within less than two weeks it should you
should be notified about its
availability actually that's a question
I'm going to have Oksana answer it have
you done much immunostaining of the
spheroids uh-huh so I first try stayin
in a fix right but with phalloidin only
I can
didn't try to stain for some other
markers yet it should be possible but it
might be some issues is antibody
penetration but we have not addressed
yet it's in a future I'm going to take
this question the question is is the
20th the highest magnification that this
process can handle what's the maximum
out of MAG at which images any process
that there's no limit on magnification
for images to be processed I think for
Oksana's assays there was a benefit of
the plate she was using and the spheroid
sighs neither have to do it at you know
10 or 20 X but the the software doesn't
care about magnification I'm not sure
Steve was with the mitochondrial assist
taken a 20 or 40 x I believe these ones
were 60 x 60 x ok that's so that yeah
that it really depends on the assay and
what you're trying to see what Maggie
would object to the you would use it
just happens that Oksana's were done at
lower mad
so Oksana did you do any normalization
of your calcium life cell signal to
number of nuclei pas steroid I did not
in fact it was done automatically
because the numbers were kind of I
choose to be reported where average
intensities of cell cytoplasm so I can
either get average value parallel or i
can get individual intensities of
individual cells it is also possible to
get other intensity measurements like
integrated intensity or intensity of
entire third as an object oksana did you
compare the behavior of compounds in 2d
or 3d and what were the results yes we
have done this study so set of compound
was compared for hepatocytes in 3d
systems and also compared with our
previous data done in to the system with
the same cells and kind of a similar
protocol so shelter can treated for 72
hours and then stained for viability
markers and then analyzed by using South
Korean for life or dead cells so this is
kind of similar approaches we were able
to get icy 50s for number of compounds
and for number of compounds they were
kind of for comparable but for other
number of other compounds it was
different so one example was backlit
excel or haloperidol we get much smaller
IC 50 for Stevie system now the question
box on have you tried spheroids from
other cell types or organs other no I
PSP derive have other sides and at g2
actually we've published last year of a
paper on using kind of steroid SI for
testing and the concern drug used in
hct116 to this color in comes to normal
cells and it was actually working very
robustly also we were using different
cell types from induced pluripotent stem
cells so we have done studies with
cardiomyocytes and it was actually
really fascinating este because we were
able to record begin of those so
cardiomyocytes steroids in him in a
culture and monitor dead um which
readouts from Virginia Trina has the
best for determining IT fifties what had
the best sort of the primes and assay
windows so we have done some studies on
the topic so if for the present study
we're from this hepatocytes were not
proliferating the best readout was the
number of life cells that steroid and
also other kind of good read out each
atom very much SI Vindoo and low
variability where the cytoplasm volume
either drum average per cell or total
personal as well as average cell
intensity those were kind of very good
markers for IC 50 some other readouts
for example size of solenoid or diameter
or intensity of entire steroid or a
number of dead cells was heaven
significant as a window but much smaller
than the other which i described and IC
50 kerf it was very poor did you only
answer this question apologies what I
asked already house compound treatment
performed was for Sonny to exposure a
daily dose
changing fresh cop on every 24 hours yes
actually 472 sa we were and if not we
didn't read compounds during the essay
but it is possible to do if you kind of
choose so in our previous studies very
did five day incubation for this counter
spheroid so we added compounds once
during this incubation like on a day
three okay I'm we're at the hour we
though i know i did not get to all the
questions apologies so if you want to
contact us directly please do so are our
email addresses our first name last name
at moda com you can learn more about our
product at our website www com will let
the attendees and register know about
this webinar directly by by email and
but for those who don't get an email we
will usually host something on our
either our website or on lab roots
website for some time so that you can
review this webinar and we also have a
another place to stay in touch is we
have a software forum Metamorpho
advisors com where we have both you know
modules and questions that can be
answered about about both metamorph and
med express and it's an open forum and
its peer to peer so that's another
resource for you to learn more about our
product I will just take one more quick
look at the QA to see if there's no
other key questions and I think it slow
down so again thank you for your
attendance and I'll turn it over to back
to lab roots and Judy and for you i
would like to once again thank oksana
Steranko and steven look for their
presentations you have any final
comments yes I really appreciate for all
the people who join and kind of I to try
to answer medications but please
hesitate emailed me additional questions
you have so we would like to further
develop these techniques and if you have
questions about the cells so please
contact cellular dynamics and if you
have question about software Steve look
would be the best person to answer key
did you have any closing thoughts I
would also like to thank everybody for
their attendance and we have feel free
to contact me if you have questions
thank you thank you both again I would
also like to thank our sponsor molecular
devices for making today's educational
webcast possible before we go I want to
let everyone know that today's webcast
will be available for on-demand viewing
through November 24 2016 you'll receive
an email from lab roots letting you know
when this webcast will be available for
replay please share that announcement
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event that's all for now
thank you for joining us we hope to see
you again soon bye